الكونغرس الامريكي مسرح لاحداث متسارعه
السبت نجح النواب والشيوخ في تجنب اغلاق
حكومي استعاضوا عن مشروع الانفاق السنوي
بسن تشريع مؤقت لتمويل الحكومه الفيدراليه
في الاسابيع السته المقبله لتمرير التشريع
كان لابد من سحب بند يتعلق بتقديم سته
مليارات دولار كمساعدات لاوكرانيا وسرعان
ما اطيح برئيس مجلس النواب كيفن مكارثي
بناء على مذكره طرحها الجناح المت الحزب
الجمهوري وهذا ما عمق القلق بشان
المساعدات الامريكيه لاوكرانيا فكيف
ماكارثي مؤيد رئيسي لدعم كيف الرئيس جو
بايدن حذر من مخاطر الصراع الامريكي
الداخلي على جهود كيف الحربيه الامر
يقلقني لكنني اعلم ان داخل مجلسي النواب
والشيوخ توجد اغلبيه من كلا الحزبين تدعم
تمويل اوكرانيا سالقي قريبا خطابا هاما
بشان هذه القضيه ولماذا من المهم بالنسبه
الينا والى حلفائنا الوفاء
بالتزاماتنا كلام غير كاف لتطمين
الاوكرانيين عند خطوط المواجهه فتضاؤل
مساعدات واشنطن هو افضل هديه يمكن ان تقدم
لموسكو ان يكون امامنا خيار سوى القتال
باستخدام المعدات العسكريه القديمه وسنطرح
بما يتوفر لدينا وان تطلبت الحرب زمنا
اطول لكننا سنفوز الى الان قدمت واشنطن 75
مليار دولار لكيف بحسب معهد للاقتصاد
العالمي لكن طول امد الحرب والمكاسب
الاوكرانيه المتواضعه في الهجوم المضاد
بدات تزيد من شكوك بعض نواب الحزب
الجمهوري حول جدوى مواصله الدعم الامريكي
الان تتجه الانظار لمعرفه الرئيس المقبل
لمجلس النواب لانه سيلعب دورا في تحديد
حجم الدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا